welcome to the Matt Walsh show everybody
thanks for being here thanks for
watching remember to subscribe on iTunes
to get the whole show or become a
premium member of the daily wire now the
big news first of all that I have to
mention just at the top is that Cory
Booker has announced his candidacy for
president everybody is very excited
about this news I went outside and there
were people running down the street just
just exclaiming their excitement for
Cory Booker to be a candidate for
president and he joins a very crowded
yet dynamic field for the Democrats a
field that includes crazed abortion
enthusiast Camille Harris fake Native
American Elizabeth Warren and others as
well including also I should mention
there's a woman called Marianne
Williamson who describes herself as a
spiritual guru she's running for
president as a Democrat and I think what
our our country really needs is a
spiritual guru that's very clear to me
but she has one item of her platform
that is very interesting she is
suggesting demanding 100 billion dollars
in slavery reparations that now she
herself is white I believe so you know
this is she I assume that she'll she'll
also be taking part in contributing to
this I would just make one slight tweak
to her idea what I would say is we'll
start by confiscating all of her income
for reparations and then we'll throw
that into the pot into the kitty and
then we'll figure out where we are will
kind of reconvene and you know collect
ourselves and figure out how much more
we need to make up the difference to get
to a hundred billion so we'll just start
that'll be the first step right whoever
suggested kind of you smelt it dealt it
sort of situation so you suggested so
you start by giving up all of your money
and then we'll you know we'll figure out
where to go from there all right
yesterday I made a suggests speaking of
ideas and suggestions I made a
suggestion at the top of the show which
I want to expound upon a bit here I
wrote about this on The Daily wire as
well you can go there and daily wire.com
and read it my thought is basically this
we need to start calling
born babies undocumented infants okay
that needs to be the the new term that
we use so we stop using any other terms
just undocumented infants should be the
way that we refer to HUD born babies
from now on now I think that this works
I think this is a good term I'm biased
of course because it was my idea but I I
think it works for a number of reasons
starting with this it is literally true
it is it is a accurate description of
the sort of person that we're talking
about because the only thing that really
separates and distinguishes a a child
moments before birth from a child who
has already been born is documentation
that's it that's the only real
difference there is no other biological
scientific philosophical moral ethical
difference between the two just that
once a child is born within a few weeks
they issue a birth certificate and a
social security card and so the one
thing the one the one distinction is
that the child in the womb doesn't yet
have the paperwork but of course that
doesn't that doesn't actually mean
anything now words on a page can legally
and officially recognize someone as
being a person but they cannot the words
on the page the paperwork cannot
actually confer biological personhood
status because being a person is a
biological thing so all the paperwork
can do is just officially recognize it
and as a matter of logistics and
practicality a child in the womb hasn't
doesn't yet have the paperwork so that's
the one difference and here's the thing
I've been told many times that
undocumented people you know have a have
all the same rights as those who are not
who are documented I've also been told
many times that undocumented people have
the right to cross through borders and
over barriers and pursuit of life and
liberty Planned Parenthood itself has
even said this is the phrase that
Planned Parenthood use Planned
Parenthood
sent out a tweet a while ago and they
said that undocumented people have the
right to live that was their phrase and
I totally agree with this statement all
people have the right to live and I
certainly would not support any effort
whatsoever to summarily execute illegal
immigrants crossing the the southern
border
I would I would not support that
unfortunately nobody has suggested it
but there is you might say a different
southern border that is quite often
protected by violent means undocumented
infants who are trying to cross the
border of the birth canal in hopes of a
better life in pursuit of Liberty they
are routinely stabbed poisoned crushed
dismembered for doing so and the murder
of these migrants is we may call them
biological migrants the murder of of
them is is especially egregious because
unlike migrants from Central America
they really have no choice but to leave
their homeland
okay now we're often told that migrants
from Mexico or Guatemala or wherever
else are forced to leave they have no
choice because they're fleeing the
conditions in their countries have
become untenable so they have to leave
well undocumented infants really are
forced they really have no choice they
did not choose to be conceived in their
womb of origin they don't choose win and
if they are born they are victims of
circumstance they have no choice
whatsoever immigrants deserve a chance
right isn't that what we're told
isn't that the the slogan they are
dreamers they have a dream these are
good people decent people innocent
people just trying to survive those are
the lines right that's what everybody
says well it applies just as much in
fact even more so to infants now you'll
often hear people say that well what we
are all undocumented immigrants right
well we're all like this we have no room
to judge these undocumented immigrants
that are coming
across the border you know of Mexico
because we're all in the same boat well
that's actually not true
now our ancestors maybe or undocumented
but that doesn't mean that we are and
even our ancestors actually probably
weren't undocumented my grandparents
came or great-grandparents they came
here through Ellis Island that was
perfectly legal now if your family came
back in the settler times and Pioneer
times then yes they were quote
undocumented but that's because
documentation didn't exist so there was
no distinction between documented and
undocumented there were no document to
people back then so that this
distinction means nothing but it is true
that we were all at one time
undocumented infants all of us began our
existence in the womb all of us were
granted the opportunity to flee the womb
in hopes of a better life and so we
really are all in that boat who are we
to deny that right to those who come
after us it is a form of discrimination
it is in fact the worst form of
discrimination so undocumented infants
it should be now the point here listen
is not just to troll liberals by using
undocumented infants I mean that that's
part of the point honestly if I'm being
truthful but that's not the whole point
it's also about being more precise and
more strategic in our language and the
left has already figured this out
they've been doing this for a long time
they've they've already figured out you
know how to use how to use language and
they get the upper hand in arguments all
the time because they control the the
language they convinced us to adopt
their language and in adopting the
language we basically cede their point
without even knowing that we're doing it
because many times the conclusion to
their premise is embedded in the
language that they use and so the moment
we start using the same language we've
already essentially agreed with their
conclusions so language manipulation is
one of their primary
weapons and it's it's it's been you know
probably the most effective tool they
have in their arsenal so they have a few
different ways of doing this and they
have a few different ways of
manipulating language on the left and
they can just be straight-up dishonest
and and use language use words that are
that are the opposite of what they
really mean and you see that with gender
issues so pronouns and all that and and
with that they're just lying there
trying to convince us to lie there say
go no don't use a male pronoun for for
him use a female protocol identifies as
a as a woman well that's language
manipulation but it's just a lie and it
may be effective in duping some people
but I think most people don't fall for
that most people still even if they
pretend otherwise because they're afraid
of the backlash most people still don't
by this idea that a man in a dress is
really a woman so the more effective
strategy for the left has been when they
come up with a new term or a new word
for something and the new word is
misleading but it's not actually
technically untrue and the primary
example of that is the word fetus
now fetus is just Latin for child or
offspring that's all that means
so when they insist on using fetus
instead of child when they say no it's
not a child it's a fetus that's like
saying no it's not a human it's a homo
sapien it's a distinction without a
difference it's like saying it's not a
car it's an automobile a distinction
without a difference means the same
thing but they realize that viscerally
and emotionally instinctively the word
baby and the word child the word infant
brings to mind a cute little person
right a cute innocent little parent
anyone who hears baby child infant
that's what comes to mind immediately
and of course they don't want that
visceral reaction so they go with fetus
which doesn't immediately bring to mind
anything because before they started
using
as the word nope nobody used that word
nobody never heard of it so they use a
word that it's technically true but it
just doesn't carry the emotional baggage
that they're afraid of and it's sort of
a blank slate term and they can they can
infuse an image and they could infuse
emotional baggage into it
undocumented immigrant is another
example it's not untrue illegal
immigrants are undocumented they do lack
proper documentation so that's true but
illegal is kind of a harsh term it's
direct it's a little bit a little bit
too accurate so they go with something
softer or something more ambiguous
something that something that makes the
distinction sound arbitrary like oh
they're just undocumented they don't
they just don't have paperwork what's
the big deal so I suggest we fight fire
with fire
and that we take their two most
effective forms of language manipulation
and we take those and we steal them and
we use them ourselves
only we are we are using them in an
honest way this is not dishonest and
it's not misleading we are not looking
to obfuscate or to get people to you
know to have a visceral reaction that is
inappropriate or we're not looking to do
that we are looking for a term that is
true and that in this case it is it is
in fact more specific more direct but
that maybe carries with it a little bit
of emotional baggage that it will help
people understand more instinctively
what we're talking about so undocumented
infant immediately brings to mind first
of all an infant a baby a human child
which is accurate is true it's what we
want people thinking about and then
second with undocumented it gives you
the impression that the only difference
between this infant and another in an
infant outside the womb is just
paperwork it makes it sound like a sort
of arbitrary basically meaningless
difference and that is true that's
exactly true it's exactly right
so let's use this let's go with this
yesterday I started this campaign on
Twitter and the term was trending
nationwide pretty much all afternoon so
I think was it was a good start but
let's let's keep it going one other
thing I want to say about about this you
know abortion and undocumented infants
is you know I've noticed something over
the last couple of weeks and that is
conservatives generally speaking in the
mainstream have been talking about
abortion it's been a it's been one of
the main topics of conversation and
they've been talking about it in very
direct aggressive forceful ways now if
you've been paying attention at all over
the last 3040 years you know that that
is a definite change the left in the
media they like to paint it as if
they've always painted it like well
conservatives are obsessed with abortion
it's all they talk about that's actually
not true now it's one of the main things
that I talk about as a crazy radical
pro-lifer but and there are others in my
camp but in the mainstream generally
actually conservatives have generally
avoided this issue and they don't talk
about it very much and when they do talk
about it they don't use the kind of
language that I've seen conservatives
using over the last couple of weeks and
they don't speak at it about it in the
in terms or in the way that it's been
spoken about over the last couple of
weeks this is a good change I don't want
to speak too soon I don't want to be too
optimistic but it seems like we've
crossed some sort of threshold and we
could always go back across maybe that
will happen I hope it doesn't hope we
stay where we are and keep moving ahead
because what we've seen is that when all
conservatives really focus on this issue
and they stand up and they say no this
is killing babies we're not going to
stand for it and in fact not only that
but they treat the pro-abortion position
as as not just wrong but as so
self-evidently wrong and just so evil
that it's almost absurd that you you
can't even take it seriously that's the
main difference I've seen of last fuse
is that conservatives are taking this
approach of like what how could any you
you want to kill babies what the hell is
wrong with you
and that is exactly the approach it
exists exactly the tone and the attitude
we should have because that's another
thing that the left has done and they've
been very successful at it where they
act like their positions are just
self-evident and if you disagree with
them you're crazy and it can be very
convincing to people because they say
something and then someone immediately
says well I disagree with that but then
the way that they react to the
disagreement it makes the person think
whoa okay well geez alright maybe I was
wrong we should be doing exactly the
same thing with abortion except in this
case it's true it's honest because it is
self-evident that abortion is wrong it
is absurd ridiculous evil to actually
support the murder of babies so our
reaction to people support it really
should be what what is wrong with you
are you crazy
that's a baby can't kill babies what
this is a this is a this is a good
change of pace and it shows us that if
we were to keep this up and have exactly
this approach and this tone and this
attitude and we talk about it in these
terms and we talk about it a lot and we
keep it on the forefront of people's
minds I think there could be real change
in this country all right yesterday
Nancy Pelosi and Alexandria okay zo
Cortes and other Democrats unveiled a
new bill which they put together called
the Paycheck Fairness Act and it's
supposed to help solve the gender wage
gap now you might be thinking don't we
already have like three dozen laws that
supposedly address the wage gap and yes
yes we do and then you might also be
thinking isn't that the gender wage gap
a myth I mean hasn't this thing been
debunked a million times well yes yes it
has but nobody has told a OH
that so she she was talking about the
legislation yesterday and here she is
explaining this piece of legislation we
implicitly recognize as women that the
pay gap and the wage gap is an injustice
that persists through secrecy and it's
an injustice that persists to the
present day and the only way that we can
combat that is through organizing in our
personal action ourselves so I'm so
happy that the Paycheck Fairness Act
addresses among many things two very
critical ones one is that we cannot ask
for salary history and pay people
depending on their salary history any
more that we pay people what they are
worth and not how little they are
desperate enough to accept it is time to
pay people what they are worth and that
has nothing to do with their history it
has everything to do with what they are
worth today and the second thing is that
it makes it it makes it legal and it
makes it totally permissible to share
your salary information at your
workplace and that's incredibly
important because for all of those who
say that the wage gap does not exist and
that it's a myth then they should have
no problem proving that by allowing the
disclosure of salaries in the workplace
so I'm so thankful to to just be able to
co-sponsor and be that backup in this
legislation that so many people have
worked so hard to bring today
ok let's um let's run through a few
things here from what you just heard she
says that the wage gap persists in
secrecy and she's right
it is so secret that it doesn't exist
that's how secretive it is the gender
wage gap is it is it's like the gender
wage gap has the secrecy of say the Loch
Ness monster or Bigfoot they they live
such secretive lives because they don't
exist at all there is no gender wage gap
and there have been many studies done
about this and they have all proved that
there's no gender wage gap when you
compare people in
positions doing similar jobs with
similar experience and similar levels of
seniority and so on I mean when you
actually make a worthwhile comparison
the gender wage gap basically disappears
which is to say that women are not being
paid differently or less for equal work
that is not true that is a total lie
period now it may be true that women
generally speaking make less than men
generally speaking but that's because
women tend to choose jobs that pay less
they tend they tend to choose less you
know they tend to choose lower paying
jobs there are more women in childcare
for instance and Social Work and working
at Hair Salons and things like that and
and there's nothing wrong with that I
mean there's a perfectly honorable lines
of work it's just that the the market
doesn't pay them as much also meant end
to choose jobs that are more physically
demanding that are more dangerous that
require more more time may require
relocation and that sort of thing and
those jobs are gonna pay more yeah I
talked yesterday on the show I said I
said you know if you're 18 years old you
don't you don't know what you want to do
with your life move to North Dakota and
work on an oil rig and make I don't know
how you know make six figures are close
to that and so that's just one example
of a high paying job that is very
physically demanding it's gonna probably
require you to move it's a huge
sacrifice it's dangerous and that's the
kind of jets like it's almost all men
doing jobs like that you go on an oil
rig you're gonna see mostly men and they
are upping the average for men in
general it's not because women are
excluded it's not because women are told
you can't take that job but here's the
fact no matter you know there could be
any feminists that might be watching and
listening right now saying well no
that's that's wrong men you shouldn't be
paid more okay well do you want to move
to North Dakota and work on an oil rig
that's a way you you could you could
help you could help your gender average
just
going and doing that but you're not
going to do you don't want to do that
that's just not something you want to do
well there are men who want to do it and
so they get paid for it that's not
unfair you're doing what you want to do
and they're doing what they want to do
and that's all so the gender wage gap
doesn't exist second thing she says we
cannot ask for salary history and pay
people depending on their salary history
anymore anymore we can't do that we are
not going to do this well wait a second
what does we mean what is this we thing
we cannot pay people according to their
salary history we aren't doing anything
we aren't paying anyone there's no we
here and it an employer is not a we
that's not something that we're all
doing that's their business
that's between the employer and the job
candidate and that's all there is no we
also why shouldn't an employer be able
to ask for a salary history and how is
this any of the government's business
and how in the world is this a federal
issue
third thing she says it's time we pay
people what they're worth well again we
have this wee thing but you're worth
what you accept so if your employer
offers you $30,000 to do a job and you
accept it then you're worth thirty
thousand dollars if you think you're
worth more than that that's your time to
say I'm worth more give me more
this is this yet again we see the way
that feminism liberal feminism which is
the only kind of feminism we see how it
infantilizes women and we're being told
that women need daddy government to come
in and go to the employer and say no you
must pay her more and no you can't ask
this question can't ask that question
she's uncomfortable with this she's
uncovered no you know I think that
mature grown women are perfectly capable
of going into a job interview and if
they're not offered the salary that they
want they can just say I would like more
than that
this is what I want and they can
negotiate and if they're not gonna get
what they want they can either choose to
accept the job anyway or they can go and
interview somewhere else they can
decline the job this is something that
grown-ups do or can do it's an option
and this is also by the way another
reason why men sometimes get paid more
because they ask for more men our
studies show that men are more likely to
demand more to do to actually negotiate
and again that's not that's not a
criticism of women and because there's
nothing wrong with accepting the salary
that you're presented if you're
satisfied with it if it if you're fine
with it then great that no problem so
I'm not saying that someone lacks
maturity if they don't you know demand
more I am saying that if somebody wants
more money and doesn't say it and
refuses to negotiate and then runs to
the government and says can you tell my
employer to give me more now that is a
lack of maturity fourth thing she says
that it should be legal and permissible
to share your salary information at work
well it was never illegal in the first
place but many jobs don't allow it
because you don't really want your
employees going around talking about
their salaries so what she means to say
is this it should be illegal to make it
impermissible to share salary
information at work which again who are
you why do you get to decide this why is
this your call why is it any of your
business if an employer has a rule that
you can't share salary you okay what is
that to you it's not your business and
also do you expect everyone at a given
company to make exactly the same amount
of money because if you do Alexandra
okay zero it does then I hope you don't
make any more than your interns do at
your job but if you're willing to accept
the fact that you're gonna have people
in a company that are paid at varying
scales well then you know there might be
someone at your job who makes three
times the amount that you do because
they're worth three times as much but
there's no advantage
to workplace harmony and morale and
general productivity for you to know it
it's better if you don't know it and
it's none of your business anyway so
there's no advantage to advertising the
fact that you know this person is making
much more than that person even if even
if the higher salary is completely
justified it's still just it's not a
good thing to talk about it's not
helpful to talk about so we'll see what
happens there
but another you know in another law to
address a fake problem so who knows
maybe this law will finally fake solve
the fake problem once and for all all
right let's go check the Inbox
you can email the show matt walsh show
at gmail.com matt walsh show at
gmail.com and we'll get to a few here
before we wrap up on a Friday this is
from Leon he says hi Matt really liked
the show I'm curious though can you make
a case against abortion without bringing
religion into it it seems like religion
is always the center point of this
debate and I think it detracts from the
message what is your non-religious case
against abortion hi Leon
well I think I actually do make a
non-religious case most of the time the
only time I really bring Christian dogma
into it is when I'm talking to and
addressing specifically Christians who
think that Christianity comports with
the pro-abortion message which it
doesn't so that's a totally different
conversation but generally to a general
audience I agree that we can and should
make the case articulate the argument
without recourse to biblical citation
because it's just not necessary it's
very easy to do it's very easy to make
the case without the Bible just just
like I don't need to pull out the Bible
to explain to you why it's wrong to rape
or why arson is wrong I could but I
don't need to and if I'm talking to a
general audience and they don't all
believe in the authority of the Bible
then I'm not going to pull out the Bible
because the thing is when you introduce
the Bible as your proof or your evidence
in a conversation with a general
audience then you just backed the you
haven't moved the conversation forward
you just backed it up because now okay
now we got to circle back around and
explain why the Bible is actually an
authority here which is a totally
different conversation and you've just
totally derailed everything and and
you've you've lost track of the
conversation completely so I agree with
you there
what is the non-religious case against
abortion again there are dozens of
arguments I've made all these arguments
many times I will just say this very
sort of the central point here I can
argue against abortion without Christian
doctrine if I were not a Christian I
would still be against abortion we don't
need to agree on Christian doctrine in
order to have this discussion but I
cannot argue against abortion without
appealing to the fundamental value and
worth of human life so we do have to
agree on that if you reject the
fundamental worth of human life then
there's no argument that can really be
made against abortion that will resonate
with you so if we cannot agree on that
so I I do need there does need to be
some basic common ground here that I can
appeal to and if we don't even have that
then there's just there's no discussion
there's nothing we could talk about and
in fact if you don't agree that human
life is intrinsically valuable then you
also can't really argue for abortion
because any argument for abortion is
invariably going to go back to this idea
that women have the it's the right of
the woman and she has bodily autonomy
and you know to make abortion illegal is
essentially to enslave her and so on and
so forth of course all of that is absurd
but that's that's the argument against
abortion right but but that argument
also hinges on the value and worth of
human life because of human life has no
worth and no value then what do I care
about her rights for but who cares about
her rights then in that case I could
just agree yeah you know what we yeah
we're enslaving women forcing them to
give birth or just making them into baby
factories well so what who cares
they're not worth anything human life
has no value they have no values so who
cares why should I care doesn't matter
so we we do have to we all have to
assume that in order to have this
discussion at all and if we if we do
agree on that at least ostensibly then
my argument is very simple it is never
okay to intentionally and directly
destroy an innocent human life period
that's all human life carries with it
certain rights certain dignities and
that dignity demands a certain respect
and that respect means obviously that
you cannot directly intentionally
destroy an innocent human life and all
of civilized humanity our country our
nation rests essentially on this premise
and it is the same premise upon which I
reject abortion so that's the argument
it's it is it is an argument about the
value and worth of human life and the
implications of recognizing that value
and worth from Jason he says hello Matt
if you could unilaterally make one
amendment to the US US Constitution what
would that amendment be and why would
you make it hi Jason I know exactly what
amendment I would add I have long
believed that there is a big problem
with serving sizes on nutrition labels
on junk food like chips and candy and
stuff like that if you look at a
nutrition label on a bag of chips let's
say like the bag of chips I polished off
last night at about 12:30 at night and
you look at nutrition label it'll say
something like 140 calories per serving
and at first you think oh that's not so
bad but then you look at it again and it
says 300 servings per bag basically half
a chip is a serving and I just feel like
this is wrong because
it makes me feel bad when I eat the
whole bag I'm left feeling like a
glutton who just had 300 servings of
chips in one sitting and it hurts my
feelings okay
it hurts my self-esteem so I would make
an amendment that makes it illegal to
put serving sizes on nutrition labels or
that the serving sizes have to be much
you know much much larger so that that
would be my amendment in fact I would
get that I would make it illegal to put
nutrition labels at all on junk food if
it is food that we all know is unhealthy
okay then there's there's no reason to
put the nutrition label because listen
we get it I know that like you don't
need a nutrition label on us a Snickers
bar yes it's a candy I understand that
it's bad for me so all the nutrition
label does is shame me nobody has ever
looked at the nutrition label on a
Snickers bar and then said you know what
I'm not gonna have that because you only
picked up the Snickers bar because you
were looking for junk food so all that
happens is that you eat the Snickers and
then you look at the nutrition label so
that you can find out how much you
should hate yourself and I say that that
is that that is in direct defiance of my
human rights or something and so that
would be my amendment all right from
Michelle she says hi Matt I really enjoy
your shut your show you seem to be a
devout Christian and form your opinions
around this without being hateful so
many people struggle with the fact that
while we may not approve of a person's
life choices we still love that person
without knowledge of the Bible this
seems impossible as someone who has come
to know Jesus as an adult I've struggled
with this luckily I have a great church
family who guides me your podcasts are
refreshing Thank You Michelle and God
bless from Ian he says hi Matt just
wanted to stop by and say you're ugly
you say that about me in from Steve he
says Matt on Twitter a few days ago you
were criticizing people who use
insulting nicknames about their
political opponents I don't know if I
agree because Trump has done this to
great effect it may seem juvenile but it
is effective don't you think Steve is
referring to a tweet I sent out a few
days ago last week I think urging people
to stop using dumb nicknames like Lib
[ __ ] or drum or Killary or Oh bummer or
Republicans or demon Kratz or or
whatever and I stand by that because
here's the problem when you use one of
those terms as you are expressing your
opinion everyone who reads or hears you
use that term will immediately assume
that you have an IQ hovering around room
temperature okay that's just what's
going to be assumed because it makes you
look and sound very very very stupid
maybe you're not stupid but but it just
makes you look stupid worse than that it
is corny as as it is so corny Lib [ __ ]
and killer II and Oh bummer I mean Obama
it's just the corniest nickname you
could ever ever think of and there is
nothing worse than looking corny and
dumb nobody is going to listen to a
corny dumb person it's like you could
even choose one of the other it's bad
enough to be one or the other but to be
both at the same time no one's gonna
take that seriously so there's no point
look if you're gonna throw an Oh bummer
into whatever you're writing on Facebook
there's no point in writing it because
all you're doing is advertising that
you're corny and dumb so you may as well
just write that instead I'm corny and
dumb now again maybe you are not dumb
but it's just that's how it comes off to
everyone who reads it so you really
shouldn't do it now it's true that Trump
uses has in the past used nicknames but
his nicknames were a little the ones
that were actually effective were
different it wasn't a bummer it was like
taking a personality trait of this part
and just tagging it to their name to
always draw out that Association so
crooked Hillary is you know she's she is
crooked she's corrupt and so just taking
that tagging it there and it was an
effective strategy it was effective in
its time you know it ran its course he
used it to affect I agree it's not
exactly the same thing but I would also
say that
listen Trump is Trump and just because
something worked for him and he got away
with it doesn't mean it works for
everybody who knows maybe he could start
using oh bomber or lifts lib I wouldn't
be surprised if Trump dropped a Lib [ __ ]
one of these days and you know but but
you're not Donald Trump the rest of us
aren't so it's just you just end up
looking very very stupid
finally from Stacey hi Matt love the
show you seem to talk a lot about a lot
about a lot of different subjects but I
really here I rarely hear you talk about
so-called climate change and the
Democrats effort to use climate change
to advance their marxist policies where
do you stand on this issue do you
believe that climate change is real
hi say Stacy I talked about this on
occasion I don't talk about that often
because it just doesn't interest me that
much yes I think the climate change is
real I am NOT a climate change denier I
believe absolutely that climates change
climates change all the time climates
are in a constant state of change a
climate is always getting hotter or
colder drier or more humid so on and so
on
now do human beings cause that change
that's the question well I think that
there is this great big giant ball of
gas in our solar system about 90 million
miles away you know just go about 90
million million miles that away or maybe
that away anyway it's about 800,000
miles across it's burning at about 27
million degrees it accounts for about 99
percent of the mass in our solar system
it is so powerful that it enslaves eight
planets in its gravitational pull nine
if you include Pluto its gravitational
force reaches trillions of miles into
space and I think that that thing
decides what our climate is going to be
not my SUV that's my opinion on that
subject
thanks for watching thanks for listening
everybody have a great weekend
Godspeed